all right what happens when an
incompetent Administration is in charge
of protecting our border well at that
point actual leaders have to step in and
take matters into their own hands well
look no further than Texas where
Governor Greg Abbott has tried his best
to protect the southern border while
simultaneously counteract attacking
Biden's disastrous policies with the
National Guard and DPS working together
they are putting down mile after mile
after mile
of concertina razor wire border barrier
right on the border itself we're
securing the border at the border where
these buoys will allow us to do is to
prevent people from even getting to the
Border
well instead of reporting on the
unfolding tragedy at the border the
Houston Chronicle is trying to drive a
wedge between border patrol and Texas
that's actually helping quote razor wire
put up by the state of Texas along the
Rio Grande is blocking border patrol
Agents from reaching at-risk migrants
including families with infants and
unaccompanied children and increasing
the risk of drownings according to a
Customs and Border Protection document
joining us now is Texas lieutenant
governor Dan Patrick Dan
it's obvious obviously they're trying to
keep the Border open and keep traffic
free and they and the flow of humanity
free and unencumbered as you and your
government are trying to say no this is
Sovereign territory
absolutely Laura and the person to blame
is one person for the 800 people who
died crossing the border last year
between San Diego and Brownsville many
of them into Texas because we have
two-thirds of the border and many of
them have drowned and who is that person
it's the president of the United States
he doesn't care that people are crossing
the border he encourages them to cross
the border come he doesn't care if they
know how to swim he doesn't care how
swift the current is do you think Laura
anyone on the Mexican side do you think
any other cartel are saying oh no we're
going to give your money back don't you
Mike drown and so what we're doing is
protecting our state protecting our
country the concertina wire is working
the buoys that we are just now deploying
are going to work very well we don't
want people to come here illegally we
don't want them drowning in the river we
even had a National Guard member who was
on in a park last year with his family
off duty and he saw someone out in the
river drowning illegal he dove in the
river to save them and he lost his own
life and so this is Joe Biden this is
Joe Biden and he puts our law
enforcement at risk our citizens at risk
and all of these people if they don't
drown in the river if they don't die in
the heat uh then many of them go into
child and sex slavery in this country or
just indentured servants sending their
money back Dan there have been some
reports of border patrol agents cutting
the razor wire that your states have put
up now hey this is Lieutenant um Chris
Olivares how he responded watch yes by
cutting that wire by cutting the fence
that we have placed as a state to repel
you know Mass migration this completely
undermines our ability to secure the
Border that's the whole purpose of why
we place that wire along the Rio Grande
river is to redirect uh to deterior any
Mass groups Crossing that dangerous
river especially not with the extreme
heat
have you heard those reports I mean now
this is upside down here
it is upside down we want to stop people
from Crossing we don't want anyone to
drown the river but Biden is the person
who's saying he's coaching them
literally you know he's never come to
the Border but if he did see he did you
dive in it's okay the water's not that
deep no this is a very dangerous
situation that he's created by the way I
know that there was a letter by some
border patrol person along the border
let me tell you look Laura I've been
down there many times and I can tell you
the border patrol overwhelming majority
they want our help because Biden has
turned them into desk clerk at a Holiday
Inn you know we're actually securing the
border with our National Guard look we
in our budget the witch has passed in
may we spent four billion dollars four
billion in our budget of our taxpayer
money to protect the border and and we
shouldn't be doing that until we get
someone new in the white house we're
going to see people drown we're going to
see people go into servitude we're going
to see people trafficked and we're going
to see American lives
in this country uh impacted uh so Laura
we're we're doing everything we can and
the overwhelming majority would uh they
support us you know who makes a paycheck
here's how one Texas congresswoman Dan
um responded to the issue of these buoys
just a few days ago on CNN watch yes
these are buoys that are apparently
going to create a floating barrier in
the Rio Grande I think it's really
important for Americans to understand
just how dangerous Reckless and deadly
the governor's decision is we know that
Governor Abbott doesn't care about uh
Federal Personnel or the Personnel On
the Border anyway
so Dan the buildings are more dangerous
than the cartels apparently yeah look
there are a lot of people watching right
now that are in a beach somewhere in
America and what we often see in a Beach
area there are buoys out there to say
don't go beyond these because it's
dangerous we use we do that in a
swimming pool don't go in the deep end
these buoys out there are sending a
strong message this is dangerous don't
try to to swim across the river it
breaks our hearts when we see children
or adults drown but this is Joe Biden's
fault he does not care whether it's
fentanyl or people drowning he doesn't
care about human lives Lieutenant
Governor Dan Patrick great to see you
thank you so much yes hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else